[Musique]
une prise de guerre dans la lutte contre
le terrorisme la france a donc cette
nuit avoir neutralisé le chef de l'état
islamique au grand sahara mort à la
suite d'une frappe de la force barkan
adnan abou walid al sahraoui le chef du
groupe etat islamique au grand sahara
été tués lors d'une opération militaire
il y à un mois environ sur la base
d'informations obtenues auprès de
combattants de d'âge faits prisonniers
emmanuel macron à s'élever un nouveau
succès majeur dans le combat contre les
groupes terroristes au sahel cet homme
était considéré comme l'auteur de la
plupart des attaques dans des zones de
trois frontières bonne nouvelle que
cette neutralisation
c'est un peu on pourrait dire l'ennemi
numéro un le mjs aura dû sans doute des
difficultés
à remplacer son émir par une figure qui
disposent de la même envergure fils gîte
assure à nos soldats mais ça ne règle
pas le problème de fond est là la
participation notamment de l'union
européenne au financement de ces
opérations qui sont menées par la france
bien seul sur le terrain
douche froide cette nuit le premier
ministre australien torpille l'accord
portant sur l'achat de 12 sous marins et
préfèrent négocier avec les états unis
et la grande bretagne mais ne
poursuivront pas le programme de sous
marins de classe attaque nous avons
informé le constructeur naval groupe est
bien sûr un gouvernement français et le
président max et c'est vraiment en bon
français un coup dans le dos nous avions
établi avec l'australie une relation de
confiance
cette confiance est trahie et je suis
aujourd'hui en colère une gifle pour la
france qui devait livrer 12 sous marin
d'attaqué à propulsion diesel électrique
un contrat de 56 milliards d'euros une
trahison à 3 dévoilé hier joe biden
boris johnson et scott morrison
annoncent une alliance politique et
militaire dans le pacifique
nous franchissons une nouvelle étape
historique pour approfondir la
coopération entre aux trois nations car
il est impératif d'assurer la paix dans
la région indo pacifique il y a dans les
déclarations qui ont été faites à la
fois par le précédent bail donne et par
le premier ministre morrison d'aider un
manque de clarté des incertitudes sur le
déroulement donc ça c'est pas de notre
responsabilité c'est aux australiens de
vérifier ce qu'il en crise qu'il en est
je tiens à souligner que la france reste
un partenaire incroyablement important
dans le pacifique il ya peu voire aucun
autre pays dans le monde qui comprend
l'importance du pacifique et qui est
aussi engagé cv ce contrat était par
ailleurs une pièce maîtresse du
dispositif qui emmanuel macron comptait
mettre en place avec l'inde et
l'australie toujours pour que la france
soit présente dans cette zone
où ok avec biden s'est c'est difficile
de parler d'égal à égal mais avec les
australiens le téléphone va sonner très
fort entre paris canberra après tout les
français comme vous disiez avait
commencé à travailler et free à
l'instant où on se parle les travaux qui
avait été engagé par navale groupes
représentés quelques centaines de
millions d'euros ces centaines de
millions d'euros et les heures de
travail qui les accompagnaient ont été
faites et donc seront payés on était
déjà en grande partie payée et finiront
d'être payés dès que les conditions
sanitaires le permettront et à mon avis
quand je vois les chiffes va pas venir
si tard permettre sur les territoires où
le virus circule moins vite de lever
certaines contraintes et de revivre
normalement l'exploitation de la
technologie des sous marins nucléaires
par les états unis et la grande bretagne
vers l'australie prouve une fois de plus
qu'ils utilisent des exportations
nucléaire tient comme un outil de jeu
géopolitique
d'employés d'un kong
qui est extrêmement irresponsables sur
une bonne dynamique et que le virus
circule mois mais encore une fois c'est
dix mille contamination par jour c'est
encore des hospitalisations hier il ya
eu 66 décès dans notre pays donc nous ne
sommes pas encore complètement tiré
d'affaires